[Music]
on this Tuesday night arrests in the
disaster of flight 752 the mystery of
who Iran has detained as new video
emerges of two Iranian missiles hitting
the plane plus Republicans on the
defensive over Prime Minister Trudeau's
remarks this is something that happens
when you have conflict and war there's
no blame here for America
Canada's gender pay gap how soon the
disparity between men and women begins
and by how much
thousands on high alert and on the run
the volatile situation brewing in the
Philippines and coming to Canada
where Harry and Megan could end up
living and working
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments in the
downing of that passenger plane in
Tehran Iranian officials say a number of
people have been arrested it's unclear
who they are or what role they played in
firing the missiles that blew the
Ukrainian Airlines flight from the sky
killing all 176 on board including 57
Canadians new security camera video has
surfaced some may find it disturbing it
shows for the first time two Iranian
missiles launched at the plane in the
early hours of January 8th after the
first one hits the plane keeps flying
and 30 seconds later a second missile is
launched it also hits the plane footage
from another security camera shows the
devastating effects as it crashes to the
ground after three days of denials
around admitted one of its defense
system operators mistook the plane for
an American cruise missile and today
President rouhani said a special court
will be established and that the whole
world is watching Adamic Haim Doug we
will punish those involved he says and
reassure people that such an incident
will not be repeated to investigators
from Canada's Transportation Safety
Board are now in Tehran and have visited
this site and in Washington some
American lawmakers are pushing back on
what Prime Minister Justin Trudeau told
me yesterday about who he thinks is to
blame for the deaths of all those
innocent people we have complete
coverage again tonight beginning in
Ukraine with our Europe bureau chief
crystal commencing Donna the director of
Chiefs forensic Research Institute says
the bottom of the plane is still missing
along with the majority of the passenger
seats the front part wasn't spotted
right away because it was covered by
dirt exhausted physically and likely
emotionally as well
they are the hands and eyes that
families around the world are relying on
the 34 Ukrainian experts returning from
Tehran are some of those who sifted dirt
and hauled plane pieces were watched
Sydney Alexandra Rubin
says they examined some of the seats and
saw traces of interference from foreign
elements cuts fragments and metal that
should not have been there in an
interview provided by the Ukrainian
government
he says the elements were determined to
be from a type of rocket they were shown
to the Iranians who were watching the
Ukrainians work and a request was made
to come back the following day arrived
at the site Saturday Iran announced the
plane had been shot down by a missile
176 people were killed Iran is now
trying to quell the anger at home and
abroad the president announced arrests
were made but no further information was
shared it's a very bitter accident said
Hassan rouhani
and it's heavy for people to endure he
suggested a special court be set up for
the case because the world would be
watching and they are we don't have the
details at the moment of who was
arrested or charged and what's the
evidence but instead it clear for us to
Iran basically wants to have the
situation resolved as for which country
will analyze the black boxes that has
not been resolved Ukraine wants the work
to be done in this country but it's up
to Iran a number of countries have
offered assistance Canada and Ukraine
continue to work closely President
Vladamir szalinski reaffirmed that
partnership in a telephone call with the
Prime Minister so many people are
grieving and there are still many
unanswered questions this is a shock
this is sensually out of the blue
something we never expect to see and
this story in general is another example
of how the world is global in every way
this country's president is preparing
for an emotional day
zalinsky will once again meet with the
families of the Ukrainian victims on
Wednesday
Donna crystal commencing in Ukraine
tonight thanks one woman's grief has
captured the world's attention she's
believed to be the mother of one of the
Iranian Canadians killed in the disaster
last week and in video posted to Twitter
you can hear her agony
as she begs the Canadian government to
help her the journalist who posted that
video said the family had been warned
not to talk to journalists Foreign
Affairs Minister Francois Philippe
champagne retweeted the video and
responded saying these allegations are
disturbing and we will look into them
just hours before the plane was shot
down Iran had been firing missiles at
bases in Iraq occupied by US troops in
retaliation for president Trump ordering
the killing of a top Iranian general
tensions were high and Iranian defenses
were on high alert for American
retaliation prime minister justin
trudeau told me yesterday in our
exclusive interview that if tensions had
not escalated those on board the plane
would be alive today and that's getting
pushed back in Washington today from
some lawmakers who don't think the u.s.
bears any responsibility whatsoever
Jackson prosecco reports so what was the
justification for the strike which
killed general Soleimani in Washington
lawmakers began probing the unintended
consequences of President Donald Trump's
decision to take out a rannian general
Qasem Soleimani and whether that led
directly to the downing of Ukraine
International Airlines flight 7 5 - and
many of my colleagues here started
claiming it was a response because of
the United States escalation we have to
ask why was it worth turning the simmer
up to a boil the White House has claimed
an imminent threat led to the decision
to target sulemani but has struggled to
offer proof as reports suggest the
president may have authorized the strike
seven months ago Trump tweeted it
doesn't really matter because of his
horrible past if there were no tensions
if there was no escalation recently in
the region
those Canadians would be right now home
with their families speaking to global
news on Monday Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau suggested flight 752 was shot
down because of the confrontation
between the u.s. and Iran this is
something that happens when you have
conflict and war innocence bear the
brunt of it there's no blame here for
America Trump's Republican backers
scoffed at that suggestion Iran shot
down commercial innocent airliner
there's no doubt where the blame lies
but there's no escaping the still
unanswered questions about the targeted
killing of sulemani how and why was the
decision made and why weren't allies
like Canada given advance warning
the greatest strength we have is dealing
with our allies and we have had a recent
history of not consulting with our
closest allies lawmakers are
increasingly uncomfortable with the
administration's shifting explanations
for the decision to kill soleimani a
growing number of Republicans are
expected to vote with Democrats in the
Senate on a bill to limit Trump's
ability to go to war with Iran
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
another big concern about Iran is its
efforts to build a nuclear weapon the
Iran nuclear deal sent signed in 2015 by
a number of countries including the u.s.
put limits on Iran's ability to produce
enriched uranium needed for nuclear
weapons but president trump withdrew
from that and since then Iran has
gradually lifted all limits now France
the UK and Germany say they're not ready
to abandon the deal today they triggered
a formal dispute mechanism in it Redman
Shannon explains what it means and how
Iran is responding
ever since Donald Trump withdrew from
the seven country Iran nuclear deal
Tuesday's move by Europe's three major
powers was perhaps inevitable this will
make
when Washington reimpose sanctions on
Iran the Islamic Republic responded
reneging on the deals restrictions on
building nuclear weapons the recent
crisis that resulted in Iran shooting
down flight 752 has likely prompted this
move by France Germany and the UK to
trigger the deals dispute mechanism the
aim of the dispute resolution mechanism
is not to reimpose sanction but really
the threat of new sanctions against Iran
is what this move is all about
in November protests over economic
hardships saw a deadly crackdown Iran's
economy is strapped and the euro trio or
e3 is hoping the regime blinks the u.s.
pulled out thinking they would get a
better deal later the Europeans are
trying to keep them in saying that's the
best deal they could get why not build
on it instead of tearing it up but just
as the e3 move to save the deal one of
its leaders appeared to undermine it
we've got to stop the Iranians acquiring
a nuclear weapon but if we're gonna get
rid of it then we need a replacement
that statement from British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson is being praised
by a Trump administration that's ready
to strike against Iran
if it plows on and builds a nuclear
weapon they've been told by everyone
that they had better get back to the
negotiating table because there is no
other option to prevent a confrontation
that would be devastating to Iran but
also potentially to the region Iran
criticized Tuesday's move but said it is
open to practical ideas that would keep
the deal alive Redman Shannon Global
News London now to some sad news in this
country a community in Winnipeg is in
mourning after a high school student
died of complications from the flu
school officials say 17 year old Blaine
Ruben Thal was rushed to hospital last
week after going into cardiac arrest
he died yesterday officials say he had
type a influenza it's a strain of flu
that causes more severe illness than the
other common type influenza B public
health officials say 560
hospitalizations due to the flu have
been report
this season and ten people have died
dangerously low temperatures are
gripping much of Western Canada the
entire province of Alberta is under
extreme cold warnings and parts of
Saskatchewan Alberta and BC saw
temperatures dip below minus 30 with the
windchill it feels more like minus 40 or
50 in some places Environment Canada
warns exposed skin could freeze in
minutes there is no relief in forecast
until the weekend and Edmonton is now on
track to beat the 1997 record for
consecutive days of minus 30 degree
temperatures men versus women on pay day
coming up how soon the gender pay gap
begins and then quickly widens plus
choking smoke howl wildfires are hurting
athletes hopes at the Australian Open
more Canadian firefighters are heading
to Australia to battle the wildfires the
Foreign Affairs Minister Francois Felix
champagne announced Canada will deploy
69 additional fire management personnel
to help with the devastating fires that
continue to ravage Australia nearly 100
Canadian firefighters and other experts
have been sent since the fires started
in September and smoke from those fires
caused a Slovenian tennis player to
suffer a coughing fit during her
qualifying match for next week's
Australian Open she's not the only one
feeling the effects Canadian eugenie
bouchard needed medical assistance she
did go on to win her first qualifying
match though air quality in Melbourne is
among the worst in the world right now
because of the deadly and destructive
fires burning across Australia here at
home a new study is shedding some fresh
light on this country's gender pay gap
it's well-established Canadian women on
average earn less than their male
counterparts now researchers say they've
discovered just how soon after
graduation pay for women begins to fall
behind abigail Beeman breaks down the
numbers the approach to the I was
looking at the male call egg that came
to my head and I'm like we'll probably
making more money than I women earning
less than men is not new but the extent
of it as shown in a new study has many
minding the gap it's unjust
it's very unjust I mean I'm shocked the
report by the University of Ottawa and
the labor market information Council
tracked earnings for all graduates of
publicly funded post-secondary
institutions in Canada using stats can
data from college certificates to PhDs
between 2010 and 2015 on average it
found women earned 12 percent less than
men one year after graduation
$5,700 that widened to 25% less
seventeen thousand seven hundred dollars
by year five it's disappointing that
they're making so much less didn't know
those deaths were so high oh the
difference between men and women cuts
across all credentials and all fields of
study so there isn't one sort of
credential one example of a credential
or field of study
while women are earning more than men
five years after graduation it remains
one of the enduring questions huge
questions economic and social of our
time the authors say a new stat scam
data set allows it to be the most
comprehensive study of its kind aimed at
giving people a better understanding of
just how much they'd earn if they pursue
a specific field an education path
information in the public domain in an
accessible format that hasn't previously
existed but there are still questions
about why the gender gap exists the
study couldn't track number of hours
worked which affects pay nor someone's
specific job someone who graduated in
one field may work in another and it's
not always easy to talk about be an
awkward question but Marie Bowden says
she's going to try confronting the
potentially higher earning staff member
at her school it's time for us to get
the light pay after that today I'm gonna
go to him an accent Abigail Beeman
global news Ottawa I had an entire
island a danger zone in the Philippines
because of a volcano you are watching
global national
[Music]
this is one of the rescue efforts
underway after three separate avalanches
tore through remote villages in Pakistan
controlled Kashmir at least 55 people
were killed more than a dozen others are
missing heavy rain and snow triggered
the powerful avalanches which leveled
homes and buried roads a state of
emergency has been declared in seven
districts and the Pakistani army has
been called in to help in the search and
recovery efforts steamin red hot lava is
spewing from a volcano in the
Philippines tonight covering nearby
villages in thick ash and there's fear
what could happen next
this is time-lapse video of the tall
volcano it had been dormant for 43 years
before suddenly rumbling back to life on
Sunday tall is on an island in the
middle of a freshwater lake about 60
kilometres south of Manila
the entire island has long been
designated a danger zone right now about
25,000 people are in shelters are on the
run because experts predict an explosive
eruption could happen at any time Mike
Armstrong reports it would be striking
and beautiful if it weren't deadly and
dangerous Tuesday some villagers return
to the island for the first time since
the taal volcano woke up they went to
save what they could a photographer also
made the trip the man who took these
pictures says he was told by a villager
that what tall gave them it has now
taken back on the mainland communities
covered in ash almost like a snow fall
cleaning up will take weeks but it may
also be interrupted
what tall did Sunday was only the
beginning mostly steam and ash next
could be a full eruption not Nikita and
not the government volcanologists said
Tuesday what we're seeing on the surface
is only part of the storm what's going
on underground is more important they
say there are literally hundreds of
small tremors happening and fissures
growing in the ground in the area what
it means is likely that magma is rising
towards the surface and pressure is
building
but this showed up officials say a
hazardous explosive eruption is possible
within hours today's more than 30
thousand people are now in shelters with
tens of thousands more being urged to
leave their homes a whole region is
being shut down anything within a radius
of 14 kilometers around tall man there
are no customers this man says we have
no source of income that is our biggest
problem now the tall volcanoes last
eruption was in 1977 but its worst on
record was way back in 1911 it lasted
three days 1,300 people were killed the
threat level right now is officially a
four on five of five is a full eruption
if that happens
authorities say they'll suggest people
in an even wider area get out Mike
Armstrong Global News in China at least
six people are dead and more than a
dozen injured after a sinkhole swallowed
a bus full of passengers surveillance
good video of the incident shows an
explosion right after the vehicle Falls
in ten people are missing several
pedestrians fell into the sinkhole as it
widened China has seen an increase in
sinkholes in recent years they're often
blamed on construction projects next how
Harry and Megan could approach their
relocation to Canada
[Music]
Prince William got straight back to work
today after the summit with his
grandmother father and brother Harry to
sort out plans for Megan and Harry to
withdraws full-time Royals William
stepped in for the Queen at an
investiture ceremony and he used British
sign language to congratulate a deaf
interpreter who has translated British
TV for decades the man was praised as an
example of how profoundly deaf people
can have an impact on their community
the news that's making headlines though
is still the future of Harry and Megan
their apparent plans to move part-time
to Canada is raising all kinds of
questions about where they're live and
where they might work and as Robin Gill
reports whether Canadian taxpayers will
be paying any of their bills there is
much ado about where megan and harry
shall settle in canada will it be
victoria where megan has been holed up
since she and hubby blindsided the Queen
for them I'm sure that it is a breath of
fresh air or Toronto where the prince
wooed his bride and it is a great
decision better than the US or Sussex
New Brunswick where this local paper
suggests it's apropos the Sussex is
settled in their midst whatever the case
the Duke and Duchess plan to split their
time between Canada and the UK this
immigration lawyer has offered up his
services to the royal couple pro bono
here's the letter to prove it under
Canadian law but you can stay here as
visitors for up to six months
immigration should wave them right
through there's no concerns of overstay
visas they have the financial resources
to be a tourist here they don't need to
work and if they want to work they can
get a work permit
so what Border Services officer is gonna
bet a career on saying no to the Royals
the Royals indeed have a large bank
account the Duke inherited loads from
his mother and great-grandmother the
Duchess had an acting career together
they're worth about 39 million Canadian
so what will they do they're not poor
they're not looking to do you know
flogging Kellogg's cornflakes that sort
of thing
DC's premier thinks the Royals to look
for work in his fair province I'm sure I
could find something for Harry to do and
the film industry is booming in
British Columbia so I'm sure Megan could
get on with one of the great may be
Riverdale who knows technically as
Royals they're internationally protected
persons so the RCMP has a duty to pay
for their security costs when they spend
time among us Canucks no I don't want
pay for it like it or not
Harry Megan and baby Archie makes three
the Royals are putting roots here in
Canada Robin Gill Global News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm donor freezing tonight's
your Canada showcases some of the new
stamps released by Canada Post the
series is called from far and wide and
it features stunning views from across
the country thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye bye
[Music]
you